[Music]
when I found out we were gonna be doing
a week of shows in Dallas I got very
excited then I realized I didn't really
know very much about this city so I
decided to teach myself all about Dallas
by writing a song okay yeah but if I'm
gonna sing a song in Texas I need to
look the part I believe I think that's
important yeah
[Music]
now I wanted this song to contain all
the most important information about
Dallas and I wanted it to be 100%
accurate that's why I wrote this song
using
[Music]
[Applause]
here's what wikipedia says about Dallas
Dallas is the ninth largest city in the
USA and the department of agriculture
places Dallas in Plant Hardiness zone 8
a yeah
Dallas is home but the 95 acre Dallas
Zoo and its population is 1 million two
hundred and forty one thousand one
hundred and sixty-two
[Music]
now has a humid subtropical climate
similar to that of Spain it was
incorporated in 1856 and gets an annual
37 inches of rain city has a total area
385 square miles and it's topography is
flat
oh and Dallas is ranked 14th in GDP by
the Organization for Economic
Development
woody I'll think about that
[Applause]
[Music]
Dallas is the fifth largest media market
in the country I'm telling you that
ain't no jive and it lies at the
confluence of interstates 20th 30 and 45
and if you like art museums don't be a
fool
well Barker it's got the National Museum
of funeral history which houses the
original bookmobile
way to go Dallas now now Andy that
museums in Houston see Andy you should
have done some Wikipedia research here's
what wikipedia says about Houston
Houston's total area is 650 square miles
all of it comprised of burning garbage
vials Jesus and smog gives eight worst
in the USA and it's home to every serial
killer that's alive today its industries
are known for pollutant and it's the
favorite US city of Vladimir Putin
[Music]
now here's my last line I don't mean to
be callous but if you drive near Houston
just keep going do you hit down
[Applause]